there are signs this morning that the
Democratic race is tightening a new CBS
News battleground tracker poll has South
Bend Indiana mayor Pete Budaj surging in
key states like Iowa
he's now essentially tied with other top
tier candidates there a new Des Moines
Register CNN poll actually has him
leading in Iowa with 25 percent support
according to that poll he's overtaken
his three closest rivals ed O'Keefe
joins us from Washington where he's been
following the 2020 race Edie what do you
make of these new numbers good morning
Jericka it's all about this mayor Pete
has spent a lot of time and money in
Iowa and it's now paying off Iowa
Democrats find Budaj exciting and
down-to-earth in our battleground
tracker just a quarter think the 37 year
old small-town mayor would be a risky
choice in New Hampshire senator Warren
is solidly leading with 31% but Buda
judge has climbed nine points since our
last poll Warren is slipping in part
because more Democrats are skeptical of
her idea of medicare-for-all than they
were before meanwhile most Democrats say
they're pleased with the candidates
already running and not looking for
other options but that isn't stopping
former New York City Mayor Michael
Bloomberg who's still thinking about
jumping in yesterday he spoke at an
evangelical church in Brooklyn where he
apologized for the controversial stop
and frisk policing policy during his 12
years as mayor the program
disproportionately targeted black and
Latino people across the city
Bloomberg called the policy which he
wants vigorously defended a mistake the
CBS News has learned Bloomberg is just
days away from deciding whether to run
for president this Wednesday 10
candidates are set to meet in Atlanta
for the next debate tournament very
interesting yet of course a win in Iowa
is not always a win nationwide but it is
a good start
thank you very much